first of all spike so glad you're
sitting down after 18 consecutive home
losses the Knicks won tonight
I repeat the Knicks won tonight
defeating San Antonio 132 118 and now to
get back on script the legendary
filmmaker Frank Capra said script
writing is the toughest part of the
whole racket the least understood and
the least noticed Oh No we noticed of
course I'm trust me we noticed brionac
don't show up on a movie set and ad-lib
for 12 hours sometimes we're not we're
not winging it we need words we need
words which is why we truly appreciate
what the late great William Goldman said
about his craft the latest the easiest
thing to do on earth isn't that right
luckily these writers took the hard path
they are the nominees for Original
Screenplay the favorite written by
Deborah Davis and Tony McAfee first
reformed written by Paul Schrader
Green book written by Nick Vala Wanda
Brian curry Peter Farrelly Roma written
by Alfonso taught on Vice written by
Adam McKay
and the Oscar goes to
Nick Nick Bella longer
[Music]
first Oscar and
nomination for Nick Bell alonga Brian
furry and Peter Farrelly
in the Best Picture category
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'd like to thank Universal Studios
DreamWorks and participant media as
writers when you have immerse lolly
Viggo Mortenson and Linda Cardellini
saying your lines you pinch yourself
city self the luckiest writers in the
face of the earth I want to thank the
entire cast and crew my whole family
all my friends who've put up with my
career and particularly George and
Eileen curry best parents anybody could
ever have they say if you want to go
somewhere fast go alone if you want to
go far go together I got a lot of people
to thank starting with the entire state
of Rhode Island thank you very much I
want to thank Vigo Marshall and Linda we
have nothing without you guys I mean
nothing also I want to thank my wife
Melinda my kids Bob and a pup there
Richard Lovett Joe man Jeff Oak and
Cindy Guster Peter Grossman Amanda
lunberg
Stacey lightsand David Lindy Jonathan
King Robert Castle Kristina Keneally
Asst JB Rogers Charlie Wesler Jim Burke
Ted virtue Shawn Porter Tom Clark showed
us and shinola watch is unbelievable
they're saving Detroit and finally I
want to thank my brother and Betty
Yellen who got me into this business I'm
nothing without you best people ever
this is an amazing honor thank you
everyone for voting for us thank you to
the other nominees what an amazing
category to be and with such talented
people this is an amazing room
filmmakers embrace ourselves a little of
each other thank you all my mother and
father dad we did it